ladies and gentlemen
a month ago the commission presented the
european chips act
with this act we want to make europe a
leader in the global semiconductor
production
and we also want to strengthen our
resilience with homegrown secure
technologies
which are invaluable assets in the
turbulent world we live in
our goal is to have 20 percent of the
world's microchips production in europe
by 2030
that's twice as much as today
in a market that is set to double in the
next decade
and it's not just about quantity
i want europe to cross new frontiers in
innovation
breaking the three nanometers node
barrier for example
creating energy efficient ships
and also developing new technologies new
products and applications
that our minds can't even conceive today
yes this is a challenge
and to take it up
is not just a question of building a few
big fabs in some eu countries
we need to mobilize the best that europe
has
from fundamental research all the way to
market applications
we need a network of research institutes
prototyping testing and advanced
production and packaging facilities
everywhere on the continent
in short
we need a true whole of europe approach
and for this of course we need massive
investments
this is what brings us here today
in total more than 43 billion euros of
public investment both european union
and national level investment
will support the chips act until 2030.
it will make europe a more attractive
place for tech companies
to invest in cutting-edge chips
development and production
and this is why i see today's
announcement by intel
as a first major achievement under the
eu chips act
an 80 billion euros investment over the
next decade across the entire
semiconductor value chain
from r d
to manufacturing
and advanced packaging
with many strong local partners
it is a considerable contribution to the
european ship's ecosystem that we are
building right now
it will create new well-paid jobs
throughout europe
and i'm sure that it will pave the way
for more companies to follow suit
my message is simple
europe is a powerhouse of innovation
we have some of the best minds and
talents in research and development
we have skilled workers
we have a stable and attractive market
and we are open for business
thank you